[Music]
what is up every damn day as we are in
Hollywood taking on the LA weed
challenge we are smoking out ten of LA's
most iconic landmarks
yeah we're used to smoke in that New
York City dunks so we can handle your
ass government-regulated weed
we're going to Runyon Canyon the
Hollywood Walk of Fame
look Brea Tar Pits so Chinese Buddha
Santa Monica Pier Rodeo Drive Universal
Studios Orlando Florida and Venice Beach
with its Observatory the Hollywood
Forever Cemetery rest in peace maybe who
knows we're clearly at the top of Runyon
Canyon
[Music]
where to live the Brea Tar Pits
wait is okay
[Music]
what do you think Ari haha hey do they
sell ice cream here
[Music]
is there like a good part to this place
or what what kind of plants are these
Jordan okay exactly
weird dude I'm over this LaBrea is
Spanish for the tar so these are the Tar
Pits
[Music]
hard everybody that was the LA we
challenged she first showed me into all
ten locations probably more woo
[Music]